after 17 years two of the most
recognizable x-men in the movie world
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and Patrick
Stewart's Professor Charles Xavier have
given their final vows as their beloved
characters Logan may be the most disco
peein ex film but it also represents a
new beginning introducing a brand new
character Laura Kenney played by Daphne
King but what do we know about this
fresh mutant hero and the young actress
who portrays her who is Laura Kenney
very simply put Laura is a clone of
Wolverine made by the transition
corporation and you need to do
everything her genetic pathi can do
which is legitimately terrifying no no
no she says Logan's superior strength
agility and mutant healing abilities
she's also been given dual adamantium
claws in each hand and has the added
bonus of a deadly claw on each foot in
every sense but gender she's Wolverine
Junior and her on-screen story closely
mirrors her comic book origins
writer Craig Kyle first created acts 23
during the four-year run of the Warner
Brothers animated series x-men evolution
Laura Kenny rapidly cut a swath of
popularity through the superhero world
getting reverse adapted back into Marvel
Comics and landing two miniseries and in
the ongoing solo series like Wolverine
x-23 was one of the x-men most
successful upstarts and also like
Wolverine she's done time on several
super hero squads including the
hyper-violent export and all-new x-men
and Avengers Academy comic series
eventually Laura was officially dubbed
as the all-new Wolverine when the Marvel
Universe rebooted in 2016 a title she's
carried since as of the making of this
video so it wouldn't be unrealistic to
expect the movies to follow suit who is
Daphne Keene born in 2005 Daphne Keene
Fernandes is the child of a British
father and a Spanish mother as a result
she's bilingual one of the requirements
for the role since James Mangold
envisions a Hispanic x-23 she's also
well-versed in gymnastics and martial
arts which
obviously also important for the role of
the girl who literally killed dozens of
people with a floor routine
her mother is Spanish actress and
playwright Maria Fernandez our che and
the father is actor will keen
both of whom have acted extensively for
theatre film and television in Spain and
the UK most recently mr. keen lenders of
prominent recurring role as Michael
again in the Netflix biographical drama
the crown will Ken has also appeared on
the longtime 1940s era mystery series
Foyle's War and the TV series the
refugees in which he co-starred with his
daughter how she got the role in Logans
Daphne Keynes characterizations and
Farrell intensity were leaps and bounds
beyond most child actors immediately
catching the attention of directed James
Mangold according to Mangold her
addition tape included moments where the
young actress clambered up bookshelves
prowling and tumbling around the parents
house after watching a run through a few
scenes the director was mesmerised
enough by her performance to immediately
request a screen test and he admitted
the biggest question to me was will you
believe this little girl is capable of
doing what the comics are proposed she
can do I think in many ways that's
Daphne's amazing achievement holding it
all together in a role as physically and
emotionally demanding as x-23 King was
more than capable of bringing the
rage-filled mutant to life even without
speaking for most of the movie
unbelievably this was only her second
time on screen will act 23 returned Hugh
Jackman decided to step away from his
17-year run as the metal boned mutant so
a similarly named sequel is extremely
unlikely
despite the amazing success of Logan but
that doesn't mean x-23 won't reappear
recently keen and directed James Mangold
were both asked about their interest in
the continuing saga of Laura Kinney
Mangold says he's wide open to the
concept of more x-23 and the young
starlet likewise sounds interested in
pursuing the role as well
Kent explained her relationship with the
character telling The Hollywood Reporter
she's complicated she tries to be so
strong but she feels so vulnerable at
the same time I really loved her I'd
love to keep playing her
of course who wouldn't love to have a
starring role in a comic book movie
franchise especially at the age of 12
Fox's x-men producer slash writer Simon
Kinberg already admitted and x-23 solo
movie is a very real possibility but at
this time the studio hasn't finalized
any plans for a follow-up the explosive
success of the final Wolverine outing
will undoubtedly light up all sorts of
new possibilities for the future of the
franchise and there's no way they're
leaving the only Wolverine out of action
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]